hey guys this is des the founder think
era and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the season 4 premiere
and second episode of boardwalk empire
one of my favorite shows right yeah in
New York's are the first episode and
resignation the second episode huh yeah
the thing about that boardwalk empire is
I think you treat every season kind of
like a 12 hour movie yeah definitely I
think it's it's not like something
that's like super fast paced then kind
of set everything up and you know it's
not one of those things it's like action
action action orden but there's a lot of
like subtlety and a lot of things that
they set up you know and in these first
two seasons we see a lot of things that
are happening right you know I mean the
first thing is is this new character
he's introduced in the second episode
but we kind of see him coming I guess me
because we saw the trailers and stuff
but this dr. Narcisse right yeah that
apparently is on a different level than
chalky he's growing more on the level of
Nucky yeah the only Kings can talk with
kings or something yeah yeah hmmm uh
what do you think about that whole
storyline with uh with Dawn yeah you
know the one talent booking agent and
his wife and kind of like how that that
club basically how he kind of maneuvered
his way into getting right and percent
of the club and I think that's the whole
thing I think the setup in itself of
itself wasn't that interesting but I
think we needed to get you know him
going to get dr. Narcisse on screen he's
going to be the I'm assuming one of
Chuckies maned you know villains you
know tagging is consuming Chuck he's not
really our sorry Nucky's not you know
Sarah the best guy either but some lucky
needs somebody to go against and dr.
Narcisse is this new guy from Trinidad
you know our idea but I mean he's it's
interesting I the setup itself didn't
interest me that mean cuz Don has never
been interesting character besides he's
just kind of Chalky's boy you know kind
of helping him out being as you know
tough guy but I like dr. Narcisse think
is interesting character you know I
think it's Jeffrey writes an amazing
actor so I'm glad to see him honors I'm
just happy he's now we can see him
because we've seen him in the trailers
for
yeah you see he's very calculated and
smart and you know even even as he's
maneuvering himself into getting part of
the business of the club right he still
knows like that this this wife of the
booking agent is is lying right he's so
he exacts his own justice right hmm on
his you know from his own perspective
even though he doesn't you know he's
like purnsley or Donner but I mean yeah
the same time he's like yeah but this
girl's lyin takes actually wasn't raped
yeah he's not like letting chalky and on
it right okay he used it to his
advantage but the same time he's like
well right yeah you gotta die exactly
exactly and then you know with chalky
you know it's because he helped out
Nucky last season Nucky helped him get
that club right but now he's kind of
seeing the problems yeah of owning a
club I'm sure like in his mind is like
oh it's gonna be awesome is gonna be
great my own club though but then he
sees like he's got to kiss all these
people's asses yes you know he has to
deal with problems with the talent his
own guys you get you know dr. East come
outside grabbing a piece of the business
and I think he's realizing that he's not
as powerful as he thinks he is I mean
he's with the African American Canadian
his thing like he's he's the top dog but
with having them especially in this day
and am in the 1920s he's gotta you know
of course with the white people too and
he's got to make it work and he's dr.
nah she seems like he might have a
better way of doing it cuz I'm sure how
can she just do the same things but
Chalky's just not educated in that way
yeah I think he'll learn I think gonna
see chalky do some interesting things I
don't think nurse he's gonna steal the
show I think gonna see chalky chalky he
loses his temper yeah yes yeah he
doesn't know how to compose himself in a
meeting you know but I but he's
hilarious to watch just see Michael
Kenneth limbs is awesome such a good
actor is so funny just watching him just
get this temper tantrum yo just get all
like the kind like a little kid he's
such a good actor yeah yeah Omar from
the y right yeah and you know and then
he thought he his daughter's marrying
that one tiger woods looking mofo right
yeah that was a doctor that help
no and he brought his family to the
client they were just like this like too
decadent this is yeah this is too too
much too much yeah yeah yeah so it's
gonna be interesting how Chucky's gonna
if somehow dr. Narcisse is gonna drive a
wedge between Jackie and Nucky or if
chalky is going to team up with Nucky
against this right cuz you wonder it
seems like they're she's like once I
think he wants chalky to do well you
know he's looking at him looking him
down there I don't think he likes seeing
the guy you know rub his head good luck
or whatever and yeah I think Narcisse I
think you might try to team up with
chalky what rocky seems like so it seems
like he hates them already so that's
gonna be tough yeah and then we also saw
in the first episode Nucky kind of at
least temporarily calming down the rest
of the the like the Mafia fan with Ross
ting because he sent Rothstein up to
almost you know go to jail ya know and
he had to sell up with what's the
Italian mafia bosses name Oh Sicilian
guy I'm Oh can't remember his name yeah
yo Joe something Joe he's basically
lucky Luciano's boss yes cuz you Chiana
was kind of left rosti and England over
to him because he's you know the guy Joe
was getting on about you know be with
your route yeah well that take care of
you don't hang out with the Jews as bad
as that is to say but I mean that's all
thing the ride was Jews Italians didn't
get along so it's it's really
interesting to see that yeah and the
Meyer is still with rosti right mhm even
though my urn lucky are still friends
right yeah yeah so Nucky kind of closes
a chapter on that and then he has to
deal with you know Eddie his is
basically his servant right yeah wanting
to be part of the business you know like
I think Nucky's just gonna set up these
little menial tasks that seem like
they're important putting money in the
safety deposit box in his name I think
it's just something like here here
here's like a little thing right I'll be
curious see how serious this gets like
the guys smarter though he could
actually be Nucky's advisor almost like
the Italian version of the concierge odd
father you know he could be his advisor
he's and he's smart and he's
oil I mean I he knows what's going on
well I think that's why Nucky respects
him is that he is loyal and that he you
know he keeps his mouth shut he does
those things but I don't know if took a
bullet for him Italy last season yeah
but you know he is I don't know how
burst he is in the ways of crap oh yeah
maneuvering and financial stuff yeah
there for me yeah and then also Eli
Nucky's brother he's dealing with his
son looks like says his son is very
interested in the business you know I
don't think he really cares too much
about going to school and getting a
degree and all that no yeah now it's
interesting that it seems like what
they're doing this season is kind of
just showing us the smaller characters
and giving them cuz they don't allow the
big the major characters so now you know
they need to kind of go some for find
something else to do so we're getting
some of the smaller characters you know
get some more character development
spending time now with heroin his sister
so I made were getting more of that I
think more character development with
those with those characters yeah and
then at first we didn't really know what
herro was doing half face yeah just
killing people's it was but we didn't
know why right I thought it might have
been some sort of vengeance thing
whenever then we found out he just got
paid right yeah okay I'm good and
they're just working for Nucky or
working for someone now it seems like
he's got a little conscience go now is
people's they have families before he
kills them I think it's the proximity to
his sister yeah by being with his sister
he's starting to feel something and now
he's you know feeling that that because
he's near family now doesn't want to
kill that one guy on the dog and yeah
now he doesn't want any part of it
anymore but looks like they're bringing
him back in yeah they pull him back in I
mean you can't say that he's too inching
of a character yeah the whole
bootlegging business yeah we have this
new prohibition officer he's like the
head I don't know exactly I don't know
like one guy's a Treasury guy one guy's
the head of prohibition I don't know how
he like fakes and pretends that he's
like some sort of oh yeah i mean he's
like well he's crooked but like he's
like he's acting like kind of like the
guys working before he's like I'm a
crooked not all he was with a police
officer in the last episode remember he
got shot yeah yeah yeah I got shot
attending that he was crooked too and
write a new cover right you know for
Jagger Hoover which they have a young
like we had this out young Al Capone a
young j edgar Hoover I was enjoying
expect to see that this episode who's
played by this one actor Eric landing or
Linden or something like that he he was
in the killing he's also in generation
kill it brought back another HBO that
HBO alums yeah it was good to see him in
this role and I'm sure he's gonna play a
bigger role yes and and how maybe
they're gonna use try and use this to
get to Nucky Thompson right yeah I mean
this is like the links to this before as
we reviewed this series it's it's been
the hardest shows to review episode by
episode yes cuz like nothing happens but
then a lot of things happen in each
episode many like stuff happens but it's
always this building and build a subtle
stuff is kinda hard to see until it all
comes together so is a difficult like
last season like it was very slow in the
inning but I mean towards the end oh you
really write those last few episodes
yeah and we're in ten let's shoot out
yeah it was great at the end yeah yeah
so it's it's it pays off yes you have to
wait I think boardwalk I've mentioned
this before Barack is one of those TV
shows that that pays to watch maybe
three four episodes in a row right there
and then one at a time right we'll still
keep reviewing them Oh course yeah of
course yeah but yeah it's more of a
three or four episode thing then you
kind of see the arcs going on right
speaking of Arc's we didn't see Van
Alden in the first episode but we saw
him in the second episode you know his
you know seeing his home life of his
wife spending the money yeah he's trying
to make it at home I mean you can't just
buy a house and just sit in the chair I
gotta have a couch or something and also
like where he's loyalties are gonna lie
between Al Capone and this old banning
guy he's kind of stuck in the middle of
both of them and then alka Al Capone
story's pretty interesting because he
gets upset that his name is spelled
wrong like he wants all right yeah hehe
that his ego want he wants to be known
most people in that business don't want
their names in the headline right I mean
he's a bit of a hothead he's
under was a Torrio most of his life so I
think he wants to move out he's trying
to get his own crew he's got his boys up
now his family yeah it's two brothers
one of the actors played a hurt in the
wire and Dominic in Entourage yeah let's
see him there I mean he's trying to work
his way up I mean of course we want to
follow Capone they also wanted in New
York eyes which you haven't seen much of
Lucky Luciano waiting these guys we know
Luciano and Capone become bosses they
they move up you know they're the heads
eventually but but taking the time with
it I don't know how long the intent I
mean we'll see how long the show goes
but I hope we get to see their rise you
know maybe a little quicker cuz I want
to see them get up to the time yeah well
I'm glad they're taking their time and
that HBO is not rushing you know that's
great yeah I mean HBO puts on shows that
even don't get like super super amount
of views or ratings they don't base
everything on rating no it's more about
how important is the show to people
right like Treme not a lot of the keeper
newing that he knew it sits on his final
season now but if it was based on
ratings it would've been canceled up
their first season oh yeah but it that
show doesn't cost that much to make plus
David Simon a lot of critical acclaim
for and not as much as the wire of
course in this show as well this this
definitely has higher ratings right then
something like Treme but it's still it's
not like Game of Thrones or used to you
know game of thrones' approaching
soprano level right hmm true blood
before Game of Thrones i think was was
almost as big you know this show
boardwalk empire is not on that right
but it's not one of the lowest shows you
know but i think because people like me
who love it you know like they know that
people are willing to pay money right
for each mayo and to watch it right you
know it's because of the you know the
fantastic riding and fantastic acting
you know yeah and you can see they put a
lot of money into it oh yeah that's easy
i think it cost morning game of thrones
like a seven and a half million per
episode or something crazy it's huge
huge budget for the show yeah and then
we didn't see her in the second episode
but Jillian we saw in the first episode
or trying to core you know trying to get
her
her grandson back and also she's in this
position now where her place doesn't
have she can't run the brothel anymore
yeah so she's not much money she kind of
got a brothel going on yeah this ongoing
brothel of one yeah but AC Ron
Livingston yeah I don't know his
character's name but the actor on limits
and he's come and I'm sure his
characters gonna play a lot more in race
uh into the storyline as well and also
Nucky going to tampa yeah i wanteth or
get some Sun yeah cuz I well what yeah i
mean i don't know what's the they didn't
really discuss to see what the business
moves he's gonna try to make down there
and we saw the preview for next week you
know he's gonna do some business down
there were not sure where it is quite
and we haven't seen what his romantic
interests are gonna be at first thing
kinda let in the first episode we like
oh this is gonna be the new romantic
interest then he was like nope no none
of that not doing that again that that
ended in an explosion so that's not
gonna happen again yeah yeah he's like
okay you can be right yeah actually he
didn't even tell her no its other people
came in and told ya yeah so yeah that's
what we thought of the premiere episode
in the second episode you can post your
comments below on the website and on our
youtube channel which is a think hero
pro make sure you subscribe to that
channel we also have a twitter account
minds at think Kira i'm at griffin de
and also we have a facebook page that's
a facebook.com slash think your fans
you